[Music]
look at this the dog snoring she's
[Music]
we just did an entire interview and
Bella did not wake up and she's still
snoring that's the best thing ever ever
Wow Bella got her beauty rest
I spoke to Sheeran about her new TV
special where she turns dumpy houses
into dream homes with the help of some
colorful language I flip houses and I'm
good at it what do you see that the
regular person doesn't see potential hmm
potential have you ever seen those signs
we buy ugly houses yes you buy ugly
house turn them into something beautiful
it's like what is going on in here it
was like a jigsaw puzzle
how could you live with that in your
house how did you do it like it's
disgusting
shirts flipping Osbourne premieres
tonight on WE tv oh my lord
the landscaping what is it it's just
modern it's nothing what's the one
mistake that people always make it a
walk away from houses because they don't
look the way they want him at the time
you can make it what you want but people
can't see possible ambition see
[Music]